even the day I met you even the day I
met you was it I was gonna say do you
remember how about me first I remember
how I first met I remember how he first
met so we were
I believe this is episode 27 I think
mm-hmm episode 27 welcome back if you're
watching us on YouTube click the
subscribe button now please just do it
it's red you can't miss it it's a
big-ass red button is red you can't
[ __ ] miss it I'm telling ya man it's
big it's red it says subscribe
press that thing and when we get to a
thousand subscribers YouTube will pay us
so hit the bar get the drift so people
who don't know it's nice you know what
yeah I'm actually doing these man of
service for anyone who's ever been
interested about how people make money
from YouTube but they don't actually
know mm-hmm and break it down for you
there's obviously a few different ways
on how to do it but the main thing is is
that they offer you a partnership so if
you're someone who wants to start a
YouTube channel or you have a new to
tell you probably know this anyway and
they offer you a partnership is which
they is when they start putting ads on
your [ __ ] and obviously yeah that's how
people get paid but in order to do that
you have to qualify for their partner
scheme if you want to call it an order
to qualify you need a thousand
subscribers which these days is hard to
get because as I've said before people
don't subscribe to [ __ ]
it kind of just pops up so I for example
I watch a lot of key and Peele videos i
watch bear key and peele videos they're
funniest [ __ ] but I don't even subscribe
to them but because I watch them really
on my home it's already on my suggestion
I don't need to subscribe yeah so it not
yet in order for that we need a thousand
subscribers and four thousand hours of
watched time that's under usual
circumstances that's real hard to get
but with flying in through it so I was
watched I'm not really
worried about mmm liver we're doing well
on that yeah loaded way past time person
yeah well we way in there so not really
concerned about the hours watch because
we're flying through those because
clearly people like to listen to them
and watch the whole ting mm-hmm but
subscribers it's tough bro you must
seems you were that bad but for real yep
like subscribe comment hate us bashes
whatever obviously audio guys you know
what to do subscribe get that auto
download and patreon jump off jump us
jump on to us at patreon so our new
service our new little service if you
haven't heard me spiel about it before
pH P a tree on patreon is a service in
which you can support your favorite
creators we hope you want it we are one
of your favorite creators so patreon
forward slash shit's and gigs podcast
calm I recommend you just download the
app patreon is shit's and gigs and it
just comes up yeah man you get all of
our exclusive content you get our merch
this should be out right now if not
sorry but the merch is excited yeah you
get discounts on much you get shout outs
on the show you get live chats with us
every month it's dope so get involved
patreon.com for such it's mean gigs
podcast and that's it that's all I need
to say to you man
[Laughter]
months is gonna kill this guy by the way
he has at least a monster a day every
day that's unhealthy bro wait to be fast
not this moderate was about no free
brand Dillsburg wants to get past wavy
if they ever Holly I think Muslim will
never pay me oh they'll never pay me cuz
I do their advertisement for free free
never be forced to pay me he would does
it anyway
hi we made him but yeah hopefully
they'll just say if anyone work someone
said just send me a cat like a send me a
single message me on Instagram him and
say James I got you
mmm I got you got you so anyway I'd love
to talk about [ __ ] when I was a kid hit
me you strike me I say you strike me I
know a lot about you but you've always
struck me as someone who's very good at
being independent okay like not
necessarily independent you're very good
at doing an adult [ __ ] okay even when we
were younger
oh yeah yeah you've got bills and stuff
you were so good at like getting our
houses sorted getting the bill SOI do
adult [ __ ] you were so good at yeah like
when you were a kid were you just good
at being that or was it Morton to have
that living with yourself I think it's
more to do with I don't only about if
they live with myself in the past couple
years I think it's more to do with my
upbringing not necessarily how my
parents brought me up but the
circumstances of which I've lived my
life so for example I have said as many
a times in the pod I've been to three
secondary schools I went to boarding
school in Nigeria I went to a boarding
school for a levels and I went to uni
which was away from my family so I felt
like those circumstances made me have to
do things on merit and obviously have an
older sister which helps cuz she she's
she is and was more mature than me yeah
and she was doing like adult stuff
before me so in terms like organizing
bills trying to find ish and I know she
she went to uni before me as well so
trying to find a house and trying to
sort all that stuff okay she likes
showing me the right so that's how I
learnt how to be the way I am yeah yeah
yeah and I felt like at that time as
well no I feel like if no one could be
bothered to do it I might as well do it
yeah yeah and it was one of them ones
where I felt like I felt like if I
didn't do it no one's gonna do it yeah I
know like we have to live somewhere and
we have to pay our bills
might as well just do it doesn't take
anything from me yeah because you man
are gonna give it the money anyway yeah
yeah
might as well and I feel like it it's
good because it's made me a
I'm very independent as it is but it's
made me a lot more independent now Oh
problems of like everything everything
comes out on my account for like my
house and everything where I live now
better just pays me the money yeah yeah
yeah it's just easier yeah yeah 100% man
see I was I I'm fine now obviously some
oldest [ __ ] but like when I was younger
fam I was scared to do adult [ __ ] yeah I
think a lot scared to do especially
picking up the phone
mmm I hated calling people I [ __ ] yeah
I did yeah yeah yeah I remember one time
my fare times one time I brought my
brother my mom we used to have to the
barber I used to use he was appointment
only he didn't work in a shop I'm glad
to have his house okay so he was
appointment only okay so you'd have to
bail him like you appointment oh wow
my mum for years did it when I was a kid
years did it and then one day she's just
like you do it you're old enough do it
and I'm like what I call the book your
own appointment right yeah [ __ ] so the
came time came fam I was shocked in my
head I just think about so many things
that could go wrong
yeah like there's nothing gonna go wrong
but it's like I'm ringing him and then
like I remember picked up the phone
dialed the number this ring is ringing
I'm a hospital racing I'm just a book a
haircut yeah and my heart's racing and
I'm like cool hi is um is James and I
was like James whoo
yeah and from then on in my head I'm
like he doesn't know my name last name
he's like okay I don't know right when
Friday cut do Friday Oh bro it's so fun
I was terrified it was another time this
is when I was older this when I was I
was 17 or 17 because I need to book
driving lessons yeah and then my boy had
a driving instructor and he was like you
want to go with my driving instructor
yes
I was trying to search for your own arms
like yeah racks racks easier it was like
cool he's his number call him up and
book it
hmm and for some reason as soon as I
call him up bookie I was a [ __ ] I need
to call this guy so my brother at the
time was like what 14 15 yeah and even
so now when little less now but when we
were younger me and my brother had the
exact same voice oh really exact same
words like there were times where I had
like girls calling me on the phone that
didn't want to speak to him on the phone
and he would speak to them and they
wouldn't know that it was really yeah it
was weird
Wow so I mean my brother have exact same
voice so I'm like yo I need to put this
driving lesson
I'm not calling this guy like you know
what my brother don't give a [ __ ] about
anyone yeah he don't care about your
insecurities yeah [ __ ] call them yeah
I'm not calling it yeah you're a big boy
bro you're a big man call him and on my
dad and Annie you have to handle him
like you literally have to like I can't
do it and I don't know what it was
there's something about the phone
something about calling someone who
wasn't expecting my call
yeah and doesn't know me yeah me having
to explain myself situated he used to
give me so much anxiety I can imagine
they used to give you so much [ __ ]
anxiety remember hold I did it but
literally I the fear that used to go
through me calling people it was crazy I
hated to an adult [ __ ] there was another
time the first time my mum made me and
my brother go to the dentist by
ourselves and literally we got down
there and my brother was young I think I
must have been like 11 or 12 yeah and he
was obviously like eight or nine hmm and
we rock and my mom's out right you might
could've got good about you making good
dance by yourself and I know what would
you mean because what you mean she's I
just go though
Dennis like obviously I've booked the
appointment for you just go down there
and I'm like cool and then we get down
there Dennis appointment is at 10 or
whatever we sit down and I don't know
you're supposed to check in you know I
didn't know you're supposed to go to the
desk and say I'm here for my 10 o'clock
appointment
it's Jeff Duncan wherever I'm thinking
oh all I know is you're in the building
and someone says your name and you go
yeah yeah yeah so we get in there and we
sat there and we're like cool ten a
point ten o'clock appointment fam
we were there for like three hours
because no one called our name because
we never told them I told my good
so with if I was found I keep seeing
people come in go to the desk and then
sit down the whole time I'm like why
they go into the desk I go into the desk
the other thing is [ __ ] I think I should
have gone to the desk yeah I think I
should have gone to the desk and then in
my head I'm like [ __ ] is already gone
tonight I think I think they're gonna
have a go at me yeah I'm scared I think
it all [ __ ] yes I didn't say [ __ ] and I
said let's just go and I'm I'm okay how
was the dentist I'm like oh like I
explained the situation she went mad
just go to why don't you speak to anyone
yeah I know what it's been I'm [ __ ]
scared father I was [ __ ] scared
that's why I hated there that's why I
was petrified [ __ ] petrified that's
why mum but halfway I couldn't do as a
kid I just couldn't and I've always
envied I remember that like when we
first met you and you were just handling
[ __ ] yeah you were just handling bills
I'm handling this and handling that and
like when you said like you went to
boarding school here and you went there
and like you had I remember you you
lived in the [ __ ] [ __ ] place in uni
in uni priory
yeah yeah you did there and I like I
remember thinking like are they sorted
out you had meals there right yeah
and I remember little things like little
things like you saying like you went
down to get the food that they were
serving and you'd sit in like the
communicating and you knew so many
people in your area and I I thought oh
he must have known him from before he
come here and you didn't know any of
them before you come there and I'm like
big man you're an adult you're an adult
I'm not coming to this city yeah on my
once yeah and make it go right down to a
communal food area and just chatting to
people I'm not doing it yeah I'm not do
man
I'm not doing it I remember when I first
got to Coventry yeah um the day we got
there they had a freshest ting going on
obviously and there were bare first
years yeah hundreds of them just going
on his massive bar crawl yeah
see no one knew no one yeah and no one
knew no one and I had a girlfriend at
the time at de Montfort yeah and I
didn't have a single friend in common
tree
yeah a single friend at first day there
and then like the girl who was it Jess
Jess yeah I lived with me not to my
daughter I'll go to this precious thing
a down like let's go me some people
broke nope no would you be meat but you
didn't meet people who nope I ain't
going I was like now I'm good I'm cool I
don't I didn't need to Mouse
she had the fattest ask Jess had the
fattest autistic abhi had she annoyed me
so much everything she was the most
annoying person she was an idiot she was
such a prick she was an idiot she was a
nice person but she was such a prick and
it's just everything that everything
about her annoyed me yeah I was so fat
mmm so it just outweighed everything in
me I would everything and I remember
hearing her bang one guy heard a rhotic
I don't they have a little 18 Romila bra
jealous I'm jealous oh my god work
sounded you tick oh but anyway yeah but
I remember meeting you had all these
friends and everything I was like rah
these guys I don't like I'm so jealous
like I'm not meeting people from so I
ended up going all the way to Leicester
to do their freshest things so I could
be with my girlfriend and I had two
other friends who was there as well okay
so two other friends that were there as
well so there would be a year's oh I had
never being so disheartened about the
fact that like we were there and of
course we met people there yeah yeah
yeah and I'm like I'm experiencing this
I you know that's not mine because I'm
so much of a [ __ ] or I can't just go
out I can't just go out and meet people
like what am I gonna say about what am I
gonna do I don't know these people
and like even when Jess like I couldn't
I could tell immediately from when I met
her she was so keen on meeting people
hmm
I knew immediately that I wouldn't be
able to just hang on to her all night
yeah I knew that was I would have broke
she would have gone yeah she would have
dipped and as soon as she
met like a group of girls inside she
would have bounced and I'm not putting
Michael back row so I can walk home at
sunset so I could walk home before it
even gets dark so Burroughs [ __ ] now
good funny
good so boy I never had to go all the
way to to Leicester to do that and then
yeah I remember even the day I met you
even the day I met you was it I was
gonna say do you remember how about me
first I remember how I first met I
remember how he first met so we were in
lecture yeah I came in with Jess who
coincident was on our course yeah I was
in the lecture sitting there pissed off
yeah pissed off and I didn't have any
bread rings yeah
not one just her and she's already
making friends in there and all sorts
and I'm like cool cool cool and then I
saw you and Aaron sitting next to each
other a new man word chinwag either from
early yeah early but you weren't good
enough or are they off see boys yeah
obviously they'd known each other from
years yeah and you go man what - Mike
and I was like cool and I remember
because there was hardly any black
people in there yeah and it was just me
you Aaron Demetrius Demetrius saucy and
saucy saucy was the funny already
braised row name yesterday was
everyone's go-to saucy he looked about
49 years old he was the funniest guy he
was hilarious the funniest guy was so
funny he was [ __ ] funny
so yes the only black people in the hope
in the whole thing and I knew Dimitra
see him were boys cuz I could just tell
yeah yeah and I thought you you and
Aaron were boys and then I remember as
we walked out they were gonna give us a
tour of the team and as we walked out
I'm hearing you man like exchanging
pleasantries just like get to know each
other and I went over here Eddie yeah
and then I was like oh they're not boys
yeah and I was like cool and then I
heard Aaron say he lives in Calais Court
where I lived and I heard him say that
he plays basketball yeah I did yeah and
I'm like [ __ ] if I want to make a friend
yeah I'm gonna have to beg it yeah I'm
gonna have to be a big friend yeah and I
remember ticks on my boy like I'm gonna
have to be a big friend right now baris
yeah I'm gonna have to be a big friend
and then I was just are let's remember
give him
for talking to that James you could do
this your pride drop your pride and the
thing is I masquerade it as pride was
actually fair mm I told myself I'm too
proud to be bigger yeah
when the reality is it was just fear
yeah it was fear of me turning around
saying something to you man and you just
like tell him to [ __ ] off yeah laughter
your face what you watch it big thing
are you big friend avoid each other baby
brother go back to that fat Oscar you
came in with do you know what's funny
because my account of this
it's obviously similar cause we crossed
paths but it's so different
yeah that's I've never heard your
account of it I've actually never heard
you're so different Hitler this is a
mystery this is your behind this is my
behind-the-scenes of your story yeah
yeah yeah okay quick tangent I was
talking to him not long to be about this
before that you would never know the
behind-the-scenes of your own story like
yeah there are some things people would
do for you but you never know how they
got to that stage to do that for you
lousy and they surprised me on my
birthday on Monday we like the flat was
more nice they put the food everything
yeah yeah yeah and I'm like obviously I
was gas everything but she then
described the day she had to get to that
stage and I was jealous
yeah they had the best day to surprise
me you never know that - yeah everything
my memory a tsunami Hagen I got so angry
about that yeah this is life yeah
exactly
you have to Fermi wherever [ __ ] or it's
good exactly so yeah my account was same
as he eyeballed it out because I lived
in Prairie like you said and I didn't
know anyone at that time hmm and I
didn't even know how to get to the spot
so I think I can't remember how I
clocked it I know I did I went to the
spot the day before okay cuz I I knew
you had you could say yeah it's take a
monster
Oh bro sorry to cut you off yeah a minor
quickly this is how pathetic I am I
didn't even know that as much as I cost
Jess she saved my life I didn't even
know that we had a different spot yeah I
know I was gonna figure it out the
morning off yeah I know and she told me
the night before like also you on this
team she said like ah what course you
own of course you aren't
same course and she was like oh so you
must be on this thing and I was like I
don't think so and she was like you are
and I was like now let me get my
look to the letter and it said it on
there like Henley here and I was like
where is that yeah I don't know we're
gonna I know we have to get busted as I
live I was gonna figure out in the
morning I was like probably thank God I
would have been borderland audibly not
what's Henley found wait
ah anyway I would have skip my first day
I wouldn't have figured out I would have
figure out tomorrow so I think I went
there it was a ver the day before doing
that freshers week period I went there I
clocked where it was I was like cool and
then took the bus back hmm
so obviously already knew where I was
going in the first name and I remember
the first day I think I was running late
cuz I got another weapon when the bus
and coincidentally when I when I got
when I got there I think I saw REM on
his bike there oh okay
he used to be that way they used to ride
back all the way there dear
well obviously didn't know was Rome at
the time yeah walked into class everyone
was there I think I was one of it before
you got in I was one of the last ones to
get in okay so you go I think you were
just going after me yeah yeah yeah but I
thought I was the last one cuz everyone
was there yeah everyone yeah so so so
yes all of that chillin so there was
seat next to rep - I keep saying Ram
Rama's errand by the way and I sat next
to REM and we was just started talking
cuz I think I had the same thought you
thought like he's that he's one of the
only other black people in this course
yeah yeah obviously
yeah obviously we're gonna talk and
obviously were gonna be boys we're gonna
see ourselves got no choice now
yeah we're in this together so we
started talking talking talking and then
you or figures I don't even remember you
walking in mmm we've Jess but I remember
you introducing yourself yeah that's why
I remember so all this talk about you
saying oh yeah the psych yourself up to
cover talk to us I never knew that was
part of your story do you know I mean I
never ever knew I just knew you said
what once was and even though you use
like you're James I'm Aaron so he's
Aaron I'm few had Beauvoir and then I
asked you all where you from
and you said North with your chest yeah
like oh now I forgot about that
like swear know if I was that wearing
off now I think I said I'm from I'm from
East or whatever I was I wearing off or
you're probably about not North London
I meant North Hampton and I look to you
dead in your bow like no one from North
Hampton calls it North the thing you
ever say you're from North it means
you're from North London bro
this is how you know I lived a
segregated life obviously I didn't know
that yeah I didn't know that all I know
is everyone else I know that when you're
from somewhere you're from not yeah
you're from North Norfolk from Hampton
that's just what it is I never knew that
until I met you no one else outside of
North Hampton knows that clearly but I
don't know anyone so a son because when
you said no if I was gas up another
London man is gonna be boys
obviously well boys no side isn't
relevant but I was like you little beg
Francois why would you say you from
North when you're not even from London
man said North ways from Northampton
like that's not even that's not even a
thing working not even a tea and then
pletely forgot that then the rest is
history I don't know how the day's went
after that but yeah yeah you know what's
funny as well yeah this is how you I've
been [ __ ] with names from forever
yeah from forever area so that day that
we met
I spoke to office aspect to both of you
I spoke to Aaron a bit more just because
of the ball fake ball team he I remember
I just come back from basketball camp
that same year that same summer before
you know all of his boys were at that
same basketball camp okay so as soon as
he said he plays ball and he's from
Birmingham yeah I said I'll do you know
this person you know this person didn't
know his person because I just met them
a few weeks ago and he was at yeah yeah
this person why cause he's personal
cause I had more in common with him
immediately
yeah so we were just talking about that
and then we got to the thing where I was
a human home and his bike I think I've
been home with Jess mm-mean you might
have been on the same bus but I remember
Oscar had if I don't remember ever and
so we all it was a Facebook thing then
in it so we all exchanged Facebook's and
I remember I remember you saying to me
yeah add me on Facebook yeah and Aaron
added me on Facebook yeah and I yeah you
said obviously my name's foo had add me
on Facebook yeah fam when I say I forgot
your name
as soon as you pronounce the D on food
hat I forgot I had forgotten it I'm so
bad with names so bad do you know why
it's funny to me because I know every
time I say my name they forget
immediately it's not it's not a no it's
not a normal name that isn't not a
normal one it's not a normal name in the
Western civilization yeah it's better to
say that well yeah as soon as you say
the D hours I've done away and all I
remember thinking is is an African name
yeah that's all I remember
and then I remembered thing is it's
annoying because all I could think was
is in African AIDS in Africa name and I
had met an African brer a couple weeks
before and his name was too fun okay for
some reason I didn't think Oh too fond I
met before
maybe his name see font I didn't think
that yeah but for some reason in my head
it was I'm pretty sure that guy just
messed names to fun mm-hmm even of
course it was yeah I feel like there's
an F and a new sound in there maybe it's
too fun and ejecting is I forgot Aaron's
name as well but because he added me on
Facebook it popped up in yes
and all I remember was like us Aaron
spelt like Aaron yes a was easy as soon
as I saw Aaron date he added you I was
like bang that's him and I was fixed I
was so vexed that you would told me to
do that add in yeah because I forgot you
know my that I should have taught this
[ __ ] too [ __ ] right I was
speaking [ __ ] he's gonna be sorry pasted
with obviously we've all said we're
gonna edit off my face he had air and
now friends yeah he's probably added
Aaron as a friend he's waiting for me to
add him and he's gonna think that I'm
[ __ ] air in him yes I haven't done
that and I was stressed bro I was so
stressed I went on there and type - fun
- fun couldn't find it and then luck
would have it luck would have it
Emre member so he messaged me hmm and
was like oh I'm gonna meet up with some
of my boys mmm
I'm fine Koster Street in basketball
court yeah and it turned out to be Jacob
yeah and someone else
and it was I'm gonna meet my boys to
play ball do you want to come yeah and I
was like yeah yeah and then he said Oh
ask foo hat if he wants to come yeah and
then I was like thank God sort of food
had sales like bang bang bang that's so
funny because so relieved
that's hilarious cuz I will never know
that I never knew that story yeah nice
that's my behind the scenes of my life
yeah that story that's so funny to me
that's it because I don't remember you
not added me on Facebook straightaway
away I mean I don't know that [ __ ] but I
was 10 years ago I remember that funny
yeah bro it's mad that's funny and then
I rememeber yeah that's exact time I
take it that same day I'm and yeah cuz
he came up to the me and arrow into the
court was [ __ ] never liked him miss and
Jacob came up and he he's funny because
I would like to know his behind the
scenes of that moment yeah what doesn't
remember it yeah he won't now I don't
think I could tell it's something about
this when it comes to people who play a
basketball in this country yeah there's
something to it in terms of like you
assume your if you meet someone yeah
they say they play basketball yeah if
you've never met them before yeah and if
you've been around yeah you immediately
think you're better than them yeah
immediately yeah
and it's no one's fault yes some it's
just a basketball metal yeah yeah so
like for example when Aaron taught me he
plays basketball I'm immediately
thinking I've been around and I've never
seen you before yeah which means I'm
better than you yeah doesn't mean that
at all mmm but in my head it did mmm
same with Jay but I didn't get a chance
to think that about Jay because he
immediately thought that about me
mmm he immediately thought and he would
never he might know me or he didn't say
anything like refer that but I could
tell just from his energy yeah he
thought he was better yeah and then I
remember we played a little
three-on-three or two on two or whatever
mm-hm and then I was going up to the
hoop he came up to block me and I guess
he was smiling he thought i'ma take this
guy yeah and then I came I went under
him and got a reverse layup under him
and I remember as soon as I landed I was
just like
the worst fear was me 10 Indies man I've
never met yeah like oh I play basketball
and then rocking up and I'm [ __ ] yeah
and I'm sure yeah yeah I'm just saying
I've just come back from this basketball
camp I played on these teams and these
teams and like all this stuff like a lot
of the guys that ever knew from the
people that I've met the camp they now
play like professionally okay so they
were good yeah so I was talking a game I
was a game yeah yeah yeah come on James
you finally made some friends don't [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and get on the court I just
[ __ ] embarrass yourself yeah but yeah
boy that's how yeah that's how I've ever
literally literally the rest is history
and I think on that exact same day it's
funny considering I was the one that beg
friend on that exact same day obviously
I'd gone off of Aaron for a few hours
yeah met Jacob played ball yeah as soon
as I got back had a shower you messaged
me yeah and were like me and my friend
are gonna go watch that my new game cuz
I told you about my new fan yeah and
we'd go and we watch it in Calais yeah
in the community new thing um do you
want to come and I was like yeah cool
yes you came and you were totally be and
he's on his crutches yeah crazy same day
yeah so Matt Toby you Aaron Jacob all in
the same day and then we went on watch
the man you game and then I think we
went we went oh yeah we just went on a
walk around grab some chips or whatever
and then call it a day
[ __ ] and that's mad and the thing is as
well as that like I said I was the one
that big friend yeah but I spent time
with these men over here and spend time
with you man over here yeah and like I
had to say Aaron had never met Toby yeah
you had never met Jacob yeah but never
let Toby Toby yeah yeah yeah all this
stuff and like he's funny to me that on
the start of that day yeah I thought you
and on first glimpse I thought you and
Amaral best friend here known each other
for years
yeah and by the end of that day I'd met
the whole crew yeah you were the only
one that only one I was the only one
I've all of us who had met the whole
crew yeah and now eleven years later
were all best for all veterans that is
bonds it's madness bonkers so the behind
the scenes of the Toby thing because
I've known I don't have said in product
before
I've known Toby since we were in yet
eight we went to school together
so the summer we were going into
University
we were talking texting Retta I was like
how you doing blah blah what you need
good no you asked me what you do I'm
going to us an old commentary it was
like I'll see you there
I was like what do you mean he's like
I'm going over to you as well I was like
Gang Gang Gang I was because I was like
I've got a boy now I couldn't show gin I
mean I don't see I knew he was on
crutches prior and whatnot but he lived
in Trinity was it Trinity Trinity plays
20-something Trinity Hall which was
opposite callous corn so I think um
after my first after the Henley thing I
went to but Toby just to see see what
his room was like just chill for a bit
more bright any place was nice what's
really good room as big as well
obviously was no questions I think I
think that's why he gave him a big room
and then please so yeah then I met that
I'm that's when I messaged you like or
do you want to go watch the game yeah
and then that was it hmm boy obviously
you've never you never knew that behind
the scenes but back then like but it's
mad because I like I said I knew Toby
Nia 8 I met Aaron and I make James on my
first day of uni and and I think I'm at
Jacob I met Jacob probably within that
week or so in that week you probably
would have met him yeah and from their
name was just us five and it was mad and
that's when Forte was born
bro that's how we all started and here
we are this stuff for that when I think
back it's something like it's crazy cuz
all the whole time I remember it's not
not necessarily case of everything
happens for a reason yeah but sometimes
I don't really subscribe to the concept
of everything happens for a reason but
there's certain things yeah that you
just like it must have yeah because like
I was cursed enough cuz the only reason
I went to Coventry is because I got [ __ ]
a level grades yeah because I Oh same
because I didn't want to do a levels
yeah I wanted to do like a BTech or
where their diploma wherever the [ __ ] it
was yeah and no fountain so basically
backstory Northampton has one of the
best sports colleges in the country
yeah called Moulton and everyone from
here if you're interested in sports you
go tomorrow
mmm and they had a Basketball Academy
yeah they're so use it's like a sports
science course you do basketball mm-hmm
a lot and I was like I want to go to
that I'm gonna do that and all my boys
went to do it and either all my boys who
played baseball went to do that
or my other boys they want to do the
football academy this is the same thing
yeah basically everyone's going there if
you're interested in sports you go in
there mhm and it's just like it's one of
those things where you know we hear
those stories of like people in America
wherever they're on like a sports
scholarship yeah and their teachers will
get them the grade they need something
and continue with yeah yeah that's
basically what Martin's like okay so you
go there and if you need a distinction
which is classed as like [ __ ] three
A's in a level tone if you need a
distinction your tutor will get you the
distinction there electric you're
sending the paper and they will tell you
everything you need to change to move
that from where it is to where it needs
to be really and you just go home change
it exactly how they said word for word
how they said you give it back you get
the distinction so all my boys came out
with outrageously good
Wow outrageously good grade the only
reason I wasn't out to go to put my moms
at night because she was certain there's
some [ __ ] reason she didn't want me
to corner myself yeah she didn't want to
say like because obviously go in there
doing sports that's what you've got yeah
I knew I was gonna go to uni to do
sports anyway I just knew it there was
nothing else I was interested in I'm
gonna do it anyway
yeah so she made me do a levels instead
hmm all my other boys went to like
University of Birmingham which is I
think was like the second best was the
first thing a couple mother went to love
bra and also fix things and I was
screwing I secured [ __ ] did my mom do it
to me yeah like and not to be rude like
I was way more academic than all of my
other friends that went as well yeah
there were obviously talented individual
sport academically I was way more
academic for them so Leon GCC's or
whatever I everyone else got like a C's
and business I was coming out with like
A's and [ __ ] yeah especially for sports
yeah I think I got the highest grade not
to showboat in the GCSEs I got the
highest grade in sport science that
anyone had got in the last seven years
oh really yeah and then so I was ready
for a new ones doing sports and my mom
said you know don't call yourself do a
levels mmm went to do a levels shock
Sports is the only one I got a good
grade in yeah all the other ones I
flunked yeah so commentary was the only
one that was willing to accept me yes
because they let you do the next year
yeah to go too heavy and stuff like that
and the whole time I was a fixed yeah I
was I could be good to son
teachers union right now yeah getting
[ __ ] sick education I'm doing this
this this and this with all my other
friends and here we are now mmm I found
out what I really want to do yeah I'm
with the people that I really want to
spend time with you well there's other
friends that was so closely before I
barely even talk to me anymore and it's
like I guess that happens for a reason
it of course my I'm a firm believer the
gallery's bro because first of all [ __ ]
that degree yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
about this degree anymore I love sports
but like in terms of what I want to do
for career I don't give a [ __ ] yeah so
it was a case of like every time I think
everything is an accident never nothing
happens for a reason I do think about
that yeah and I think if I didn't get
those cheek if my mom didn't force me to
do it
mmm I never would have gone to
commentary and never would have met you
man we would not be saying right now
yeah honey literally would not and there
be so many things that have happened in
the last 11 years I'm so different that
be completely different yeah completely
different I know for a fact I wouldn't
be sat here doing this one yeah and it's
like this is the only place I want to be
yeah and I'm so happy that I'm here with
you doing it and if I'd got my own way
when I was younger yeah I wouldn't be
here a human being and I'd probably be a
[ __ ] physio yeah in in Leicester
somewhere for the [ __ ] second team
Leicester [ __ ] [ __ ]
you had the 21 Leicester team and I'm
like oh yes this is a good job yeah I
[ __ ] hate my life
yeah and like yeah so it's stuff on this
Matt Matt I like I like what you said
about the behind this behind the scenes
behind like when you said I want to tell
you the behind the scene of your story I
was like that sounds juicy bro it's cuz
the reason why I said is cuz of the
birthday thing that have planned for me
I was like I'm never gonna experience
like I'm never gonna have that memory in
my head because I wasn't there so that
was my that was there behind the scenes
of my birthday a crazy Park it was
amazing to raise equerry it's amazing to
do sick alright to wrap it up yeah mum
can't get upset